as christian mentioned state leaders
have approved a new substitute
regulation and it allows those with a
high school diploma or an equivalent to
apply for a teaching license in nevada
but only during an emergency declaration
mary jane belliesa shares how the
commission of professional standards are
responding nevada department of
education wants to make this permanent
but there are concerns about how
qualified applicants are with just a
high school diploma and limited training
it's been an ongoing problem even before
the pandemic not enough teachers and not
enough substitutes kenny belknap with
the commission and educator at liberty
high school says emergency substitute
teachers need more training i find it
troubling especially with these
emergency sub licenses that we're saying
it's okay that you know someone with a
high school equivalent diploma can serve
as a long-term sub someone who can serve
in a classroom with you know 40 plus
kids for an entire school year teaching
them the content area that they need
under this emergency declaration
and
you know there's no accountability the
commission has provided accountability
recommendations suggesting subs
routinely meet with administrators and
undergo an evaluation process
commissioner jordan wenger agrees with
this proposal i'm just really concerned
that these emergency substitutes are
being used in our title 1 schools more
frequently
and those are our kids that are
need the best instruction so i want to
make sure that this regulation
is
giving them that accountability
of getting the best
teachers in there that are qualified
currently there are 600 emergency subs
in clark and washoe county school
districts these subs will be teaching
for the remainder of the school year and
next year if nevada remains under a
state of emergency i look at the
emergency situation right now it's a
temporary thing we're doing a lot it
looks like we're doing a long-term fix
to a temporary problem
i think a real fix to this is the
district's really looking at what
they're doing with their subs providing
better pay
incentivizing people to work for them
rather than relying on state regulations
reporting in the newsroom mary jane
ballisa live local now